how's it going bros buddies bad back
welcome to infamous first light this is
a deal see that came out just a few days
ago and how lucky are we to just to
finish the game and then get a dlc that
looks awesome by the way so that's
pretty cool I feel like it's obvious
that we have to play this I know some of
you were hoping for coops party it's
coming don't worry but we got playing
this first it makes sense
plus I want to play this you can't stop
me
a little bit a bat ello backstory day we
don't need that win why is it shaking so
I I bet my tongue
it hurts a lot if I don't [ __ ] normally
you know why
great sorry I wish Nelson was in this
but supposedly you play us a girl you
know the funky hair girl damn what is
happening what is this oh this is the
prison cool do we get to escape that'd
be awesome
your intro is unimaginable but I can't
help you unless you open up so she's
still alive now the evil
please tell me what happened okay she
looks scary
fetch her name I forgot about that I
thought she was telling her to fetch
some honey and when they found that I
had powers I was Tony stroke but my
brother Brent he always took care of me
he just grabbed my hand and we've ran
spent a few years living on the streets
staying out of sight keep it on the move
we did some shitty things to make money
but that job we pulled before leaving
Seattle marcin the rest of it combined
so this is before she got taken care of
come on sis it's just one more job so
load it up let's just go no this one's
too payday
huh how much enough to rent a decent
place yeah yeah enough for a
short-tailed Burmese cat huh hello
it's not for a fresh start we could use
one [ __ ] get out get out how did they
not hear them you hide hide I'll
distract them
no wait you do this job we leave tonight
no one will be able to find us yes no no
do not use your power she's gonna kill
anyone just carry my weight what does
that mean [ __ ] okay hey ed you later
time I'm over here look at me eyes up
right here
oh we're controlling this I sorry look
in version options no thanks
if I search that Bodi or wait you want
to see a trick press and hold to run a
Lightspeed hey yeah
whoa she can do it forever look at this
Ren always pushed me to keep my power
secret if anyone knew a Conda Bert was
in town there'd be a manhunt and it
happened before but that night I wasn't
worried I've used my powers to get the
job done then the two of us would take
off we'd be miles away before the DUP
show why do I have a feeling the guy's
gonna betray her as soon as [ __ ] goes
down so typical so men I would never do
that Gale I missed this oh I gotta do
it's avoid the police whoa look at I
this is amazing
I'll go in here whoa sanic sanic saw me
fast he didn't make out out than me
right now that was the sentence yep
I said it you're welcome look at this
it's amazing I never really upgraded
this power with a dalton Delson whatever
I keep pretty heavy hi okay we had to go
underneath cover just gonna stay out of
sight I'm gold Oh how's that way great
he says yeah I'm fine as soon as you
started the glow whole city went crazy
this is too dangerous we need to leave
now DUP is coming I thought you wanted a
fresh start and you know I want that cat
just tell me what the job is I can do it
ah that cat fine just be fast it's the
penthouse at third and stone break in
grab the red duffel bag be fast what's
in the bag alright I cop let's look like
this down of that
I'll get out of Dodge Bo's
damn Oh
he became a bench you're welcome he
always wanted to be a bench what is he
doing like uh uh everything hurts
ow why did you have to punch me God
whoops sorry he's dead well I ended his
suffering I feel like I did him a favor
hi so this is it's cool to see the city
before all the conduits and [ __ ] had
came oh god I wish had powers like this
I would just go sanic mode all the time
we should be here somewhere
where's that apartment well she can go
through that's awesome look at that
every I wonderful wait let's enter come
on well good thing we have our neon bolt
why can't we just sprint through
are you serious we're gonna blow it up
alright yes pony a nice tracksuit wow
you guys look really cool bet you guys
get a lot of ladies I'd actually like
you let me kick your ways man [ __ ] your
couch [ __ ] your couch Maine that's how
it's done
pick up the bag there it is so I get to
click yes I love this part best gameplay
ever ten out of ten well but here's
another bag can I click on I - come on
and I gotta give it a 8 out of 10
oh hello oh hello can she survive this
whoa
hi charge up I'm gonna need it the power
of gnosis apparently was offensive when
I when I snorted it so there we go
love that sound okay what happened place
was full of Russians dancing around
applause high five current they found
out some who my boss he knew about the
pen Houston
little about our poet we gotta go now hi
warm up the engine
I'll be right there I'm sorry about all
this I really wanted to get you that
Burmese yeah
next okay how expensive are cats these
days like come on goddamn seeing all the
smoke I'm like wait where'd stelson up
there calling oh look it's clean car
just outside they got guns what I'll be
right there
no these guys we keepin it together just
fine
I got you hang up and hide them come on
we're still going there it's so far how
would I all right take the bridge got it
cool you can do this bill texting can it
wait that's true Brice don't text and
drive
love all the messages in this game last
game ahead like old raw anti-drug
messages this is anti-riot picks and
iron that's fantastic and of course this
game has the best color of all time I
gotta say how do I get there
okay so it's by the end of the dock got
it alright gotta go so fast I'm saying
Inc oh god that was what today explode
what right
he's Mohawk is not gonna look as hot now
oh wait it it's actually gonna decline
right
go ahead w-where are you
someone has exact same phone is bright I
need you whenever I'd start to freak out
I focus on Brent's it was the only thing
that calmed me down I call into a good
memory
where's night in Seattle we found this
overpass and got out of the rain ended
up reading comics by flashlight until we
fell asleep later this guy snuck in and
tried to steal what little we had and I
was about to make you pay for it that
night we established the rules rule
number one no powers no matter what why
we might lose some gear
but Brent didn't want us to lose us Oh
shouldn't use my powers whose my mommy
was gone it wasn't mine oh this is her
super ability that looked awkward as
hell if I go don't let me go like that
those breaks from reality changed me I'd
wake up with new powers it was like my
body decided to fight but my mind gave
up hmm you've been very forthcoming
miss Walker no it's a little break you
can show me the skill you acquired from
your mental snap
I thought you wanted to get control of
your powers that's what we're here for
I don't know last time I used we'll
start with something simple I'll be
watching your progress from up there
please don't try anything stupid all I
do is stupid
no miss Walker you're a survivor so they
let them use their powers in their
interesting that's an interesting chair
as well oh damn look at that everyone
has a weakness you just have to look
forward she could easily set this up
yeah hold LT to zoom and destroy the
statues I have to swim in to use it okay
so they all have different weak points
got it he's literally Achilles heel not
bad not great thanks Buddha just started
perhaps you'd like more relatable
targets nice yoga paints impressive are
they these hard light Holograms look and
feel Murray now please kill them
what if he's our mindlessly shoot things
okay oh the conduit up here making those
Holograms YouTube he won't mind what's
the point the point is survival
not just for you but for those who can't
defend themselves go on protect him
all right I'll see you later alligator
hater you're welcome Berta oh sorry
sorry I approached the hostage collect
thank God for Yoga pain clock's ticking
find and save the hostage oh sure
brofist also that actually works
okay his hand is his weak spot his face
is in week one
yes it was that ugly huh hi we're dead
oppressed high-five wasn't the fastest
time you complete a challenge press
option to pause okay I have more
challenging in here let's buy this one I
guess like that you've proven basic
mastery but are you tenacious miss
Walker when presented with a challenge
by Chuy's me or hans on gods
well there's a lot more to do now yeah
yeah all the prophets Piper brofist oh
[ __ ] set it [ __ ] bad-ass oh good I by
the power of gnosis a greatest sniper
climb now wait second grader thanks
Moses another hostage oh god where would
you but he's fake I don't care it's like
Harry Potter not real
actually I do care my Hydra [ __ ] god
damn it how does it work no no problem
I'll have the hostage get all excited
like oh yeah yeah she looks so fat when
she ever got brofist hai stop shooting
my best friend
okay so close then I save them oh that
was close man that was close there we go
Oh last hostage for Jabba I don't know
why I said boo job uh that's offensive
yes we did it oh my god he almost got
bird whoa performance
oh my hostage exercises we keep school
you know other condors achievements are
posted to irritate inspire you I'm
always open war training perhaps you'd
like to surpass them here we go he'll do
for now
take a seat
that Chairman resumed your explanation
what happened in Seattle there with two
years ago tearing up the city looking
for my brother he's ended up back at
what was left of our boat that's where I
met him he was looking for Brent too
what the hell
nice haircut douche excuse me sweetheart
I'm sorry have you seen a fella knocking
a mohawk around here somewhere
wait you know you know Brent are you
with those Russians Leah Kern's hell no
Bart are you saying they're the ones who
did this dammit the keep shouldn't
happen my employee sweet do you know
where they happen can you take me oh no
down there sugar I'm sure you do not
want to get that pretty face caught up
in all this trouble you know I don't
know what you had worked out with Brent
but does my brother help me
are you fetch I'm Shane Jane no Bret
never told me that his sister was such a
pretty little thing just tell me where
to look
beside mainly thank you and if you think
of anything else then call me on friends
phone alright yeah yeah sure whatever
you say sweetheart just make sure you
take care of that all right never seen a
man so scared of pink before Jesus I
gotta get this city ready for the real
me need some meal
lots of neon all right friends gotta end
that episode there I hope you enjoyed
watching I think it's great to revisit
the world of infamous I hope you both
feel the same way please go ahead and
leave it like I would very much
appreciate it bro and that's all for me
now seeing the next one as always stay
awesome